this is set to be just a ridiculous
matchup here now combine is set the
remote Egyptian Egyptian Sahara this
vertical farming and sustainability
research facility pays fast and frantic
with tight interiors an open middle and
a dangerous flank path I think this is
going to be an absolute battle we've had
some really really back-and-forth games
throughout the past couple days right
the middle of the map gets crazy and you
know you're able to win those gun
engagements with assault rifles from
base to base kind of wall you can
actually wall run to the opposing teams
base and then that far side of the map
has that wall running spot all the way
on the opposing side so that it's a good
flanking area to get to the opponent's
base then you're gonna have the other
side it's gonna have just a rocky area
where you're gonna have to win some
close-quarter gun engagements in but I
love about this map is viable for SMG
players and assault rifle players right
you know the SMGs can go on the flanks
play close quarters on the outside and
then the ARS can dominate the middle
yep it's certainly going to provide a
good variety now we talked about bans
and protects and how influential they're
going to be on the game let's kick it
off this is going to be the first
glimpse here of the live band protect
system yes so Tommy and since were both
gonna go at the same time here and it's
pretty much a race easy sensor he's
gonna ban that thermal sight and Tommy
he's gonna go for the UAV so both those
players are gonna go go down to the next
two players in line yep we'll keep
ripping through here see what players
are trying to eliminate you know it was
really awesome just watching through the
course of that first day how dynamically
a changed game by game his player
started to adapt to each other's place
down right cuz the players started to
ban you know the guns that the other
players were good with and then it's all
you know game to game game mode to game
mode really changed see gotaga he's
gonna protect that m8a 7/5 favorite of
everyone from like we've seen that in a
use so much not surprised that's the
first one protected you'll see flex
going to be banning the mothership and
then keyd will protect that outer
teammate though that's pretty fun so
what a perception so has been ripping
when I here's where you know the
strategy comes into it you know buzzing
has that last ban he's not going to be
able to really no mirc would have
probably been the man of war right there
you know that's been buzzes go to he
ends up getting rid of 6/10 and then
buzz gets rid of c4 at the end and now
we have the specialist RAF maven yep
this is huge now we've seen a lot of
different game types we've seen how
these players have adapted again
the course of the past couple days these
pics are going to start to come in
you're gonna see Annihilator coming in
his first pick for censor and Tommy tell
me a little bit about that specialist
class yes oh the Annihilator is that
massive high caliber revolver with
penetration rounds no you're gonna see
players try and pick up lots of kills on
the outside you're gonna see TP go with
ruh and overdrive you expect that out of
a lot of the obj players let's you to
move fast around the map gotaga going
for that out writer Sparrow it's gonna
be a knife that Bobi will do you know we
haven't seen it used to Tom we'll see if
it could be used to effect in this hard
point and then reject you'll see that
coming in on both teams tell me a little
bit about reject Matt sorry jack when it
you die allows you to come right back to
life you know there's a smoke around it
it's great for you know players I want
to hold down positions and then they
want to get a second chance of a right
you know you have to use it at the right
time or else it's not gonna be as
effective you see the last two players
it's gonna be a prophet tempest from
Merc and then buzz I'm gonna go with
that Reaper psychosis that's one that
we've seen a lot of players do some nice
stuff with oh yeah the psychosis you
know you're gonna have those Holograms
you've seen them use the drones able to
but defensively we've seen it
offensively and hardpoint specifically
you know you'll have people set up in
the heart but you're trying to bust in
you send out the holograms provide a bit
of a distraction than you're able to fly
in with a sub fly with the AR make a big
play on the hardpoint it's just been
it's been phenomenal for me to see just
how quickly I mean I know it's to
relieve elevating how they've been using
this stuff right it's a birthday we saw
them just kind of basically using them
know just randomly whatever they got
them now you're seeing them time when
they use these specialist abilities
really know coming watch I mean we've
seen a few times we know that region has
come in don't save the team from losing
those spawns then we've seen something
with the Prophet Tempest know it's able
to just jump into a hill clear weak
weakened you know two or three opponents
so it's gonna be interesting game to
game how it's gonna change and you'll
see here the one bit we didn't talk
about you get to edit your class and
score streaks before we hop into the
action obviously with how much more that
verse this games going to be how much
more you have to be familiar with
different weapons different scores
source reeks before each game you're
gonna have a chance to edit your class
get everything set to go as soon as
players ready up will be ready to hop in
again game one is going to be hard point
on Kaiba comet I cannot wait to get the
action Matt and as a team you're really
gonna have to work together to pick you
know what are we gonna been what are we
going to protect what order we're gonna
do it in and then as we said before it's
a race so those first two players are
trying to ban and protect the same thing
it's to whoever gets there first
alright Game one team
Givi going up against team TP all right
I know this isn't the finals of a
tournament but I still need a prediction
out of Matthew can you pick him this one
I know team TP is pretty strong
I'm really wanting to see how buzz odo
plays for Team keavy he's got that
Reaper so that was just you know with
the assault rifle you imagine they
protected the man-of-war he's going to
have that his hands gonna be interesting
to see how he's gonna play well speaking
of what you talked about buzz oh I'm
gonna kick things off with him as we're
getting ready to hop into the action
what's bound to be an amazing game 1
again you're gonna see them fight over
this middle hard point it's gonna be
right in the center of the map gonna be
teams fighting from all over the place
you'll see teams going all the way up to
that top side you're gonna see that
green arrow try and get to the other
side of that map for that flank and then
the left-hand side you're gonna see
players try and win those close quarter
engagements and then just slide out and
take that middle hard point yep you can
see via the x-ray obviously that is just
for you viewers at home and us caster is
able to get vision on where the pushes
are coming for buzz oh is going to be
taken out after he started out
two-and-oh gonna switch over to team TP
Tommy also to know he's set up in the
hardpoint right now trying to get as
much time as he can for his team out to
an early lead here now about one thing I
want to touch on is we're early into the
game we have a little bit of time to
talk here
this has been a great addition you have
the ability here now oh yeah you pull up
the widget here for each player you can
go through you'll see at the bottom
middle of the screen you can see
psychosis he is the man of war you can
go through all the perks see everything
that they have on their class able to
pop it right back out it's incredible
here for us ever you at home to see
what's going on it's such a great little
graphic end feature in the cod caster
mode I mean makes it so easy for the
broadcaster just looks great
professional you see Buzzo
on a five streak now has that psychosis
ability will be interesting seen when
going signs to use that he's getting
close to the streaks as well maven so
gonna try and set up for this next he'll
regen some he'll try and get those
streaks as no we remember back to black
ops 2 competitive play how large were
score streaks uh huge HS completely
changes the game it's amazing to have
them here in black ops 3 as we'll see
buzz oh so close to streaks and now he's
gonna have it set up going to have else
or missile gonna be set up for when he
comes off as bumbles gonna stay on with
him is he's got his special ability oh
he's feeling
he has his specialist ability he has to
scorestreaks the hell's from in that
Guardian will decide when is it and
that's what's gonna be the whole
metagame right now you're gonna have
that free match metagame deciding what
we're gonna protect what we're gonna ban
what specialist we're gonna and then in
game right nope
when we do sports drinks is such a large
part of black ops suit
now it's when who's your score streaks
and specialist abilities because those
special abilities can change around the
game right no this heart points so close
let's say there was a ruin with the
gravity spikes he was able to just jump
in there clear a hard point out like
that you wouldn't want to waste that you
see that is going to be the no man using
his reject ability to come back to life
right there hard yeah I'm gonna keep
eyes on well with Tommy real quick just
cuz he's 9 and 6 he has the Annihilator
in his pocket when he's ready to use
that we've seen that be used very
effectively in different game modes
there it is there's the one-shot kill
Kenny Oh pick it up as he's heating up
with the United he's got five shots left
in that they've got a 23 point advantage
here and Tommy starting to roll and
we've seen some players do some great
things with United absolute destroyers
gotaga there and no they're just able to
push out those bonds and really just
lock it down for the team and how huge
on a hard point mavens when your team
gets control you're either push out take
two three players out for the next wave
of the opponent table of by your team
you know twenty thirty seconds on the
hill are well be at GV in the hill he's
11 and I'm gonna end up dropping here
they're trailing big time we've seen
some great comebacks in this game
already as we've been watching just the
action again over the past couple days
we are see sensor here he's gonna push
forward with the kuda not able to win
that gunfight he is going to end up
dropping they're starting to mount the
comeback right now for Team TV and I got
to go back to buzz Oh though he hasn't
even used a streak set he's still
holding on to the specialist I'm gonna
keep going back to him just to you at
home to get naive when he's gonna start
to put these into a thought yeah you
just
psychosis come into effect it's gonna be
awesome see see that no man ability that
reject coming into effect again he had
no idea where that player was gonna come
up and go once he's out of that smoke
and see puzzle gets taken out by that
guy but it's all timing on when to use
these Maeve and you see puzzle just
waiting for the perfect opportunity to
do so because his team is still pretty
close in the game right there's no
reason to panic right now still six
minutes twenty seconds to go you're
gonna expect him to hold on to it when
it's really no in a clutch situation and
TP right now on the TTP starting to pull
away if it here forty point advantage
I'm gonna stay with him through the
respawn he's sixteen eleven you can see
he has his specialist ability locked and
loaded as well beginning to heat up here
start to really pull away
excellent job from his side thus far the
specialist abilities are gonna change
from Player to Player you see the
overdrive it's gonna be activated by TP
he's gonna get that fast player movement
cross man we're gonna see obj player in
lots of you know objective a stable
obviously use this and as he's using
that kudo kuda probably the favorite of
the SMGs from the players list oh yeah
you can see how fast he was able to get
it give the action get back to that hard
point pick up the two pieces there with
the sub great stuff from TP and they're
completely in control this game about
the lack of to try for competitive games
there was the obj players the anchors
now with the specialist abilities you're
gonna have different you know bankers
and obj players played differently like
an anchor for instance could probably
use the outriders feral the compound
book now able to just stay at range and
pick players off maybe they use you'll
be Annihilator pistol able to pick up
some easy kills on the rotation or even
nope you could say you use the combat
focus no earth tours for streaks well
activated rank them up and here's you
see the compound bow coming back oh
sorry since they're gonna stick that one
of your back he's gonna tag him up just
trying to pick one up get all workers
and it comes the sparrow kill four go
tog as he's in arm animation when he
hits him with the boat just awesome
watch the players fly back you see Tommy
with that Annihilator pistol yet again
picking up another one he has been so
good on when to use that nope he's done
a great job knowing when the players are
coming on spawning from where and then
using that special ability it will pick
up to three kills for his team and buzz
oh push again still has the hellstorm
still has his special
work with is well he's got three players
in front getting pushed not able to
clean it up you can see we've got like
5:45 on the clock right now
and this was just continues to pull away
here the NUC flexing with the CUDA gonna
be playing pretty obj mind and nearly
he'll it's gonna have one player use
that reflex billing outside now they're
just gonna watch the side door hard
point is such a great game on Navin you
know for the people new at home launch
explain what hard point is I mean for
harm over T to a max of 250 obviously
this is going to be rotating basically
on a 60-second timer as they're gonna
look to control you know you call it the
hill basically you're trying to lock
down this area and so far it's been team
tp'ed is completely controlling and
that's really on the back of TP and
Tommy you can see tommy doing it
objectively he's been doing it in a
slight department as well who's really
been jumping out for you on both these
sides Matt I know Tommy he's been so
smart with the way he's used his
abilities over he's back in it right I
mean he's got that tempest he's gonna be
able to use that in case they get the
hill right so that it's gonna be
something that you can charge up fires a
little bit of electricity shocking
targets chaining to nearby enemies so
let's say there's a power plant where
the opposing team has to three players
in he can charge it up hit one jumps
from player two player gets them weak
opportunity for his teammates with the
SMGs to push in yeah I want to get back
to mark in just a second cuz he has the
whole sort of work with as well became
on the tail end of his lightning strike
I know Tommy had the Annihilator but
let's see what he's able to do here Merc
trying to push forward his tempest so
he's gonna charge this up trying hit one
of these players see if it jumps from a
player he's gonna shoot it but not able
to pick one up I do like he got one I
think that transferred over I didn't see
if the second player was able to get
cleaned I like a little too use it
though right no the opposing team had
the ill you knew there was gonna be two
or three players in this short area and
you see mark
picking up a big three piece there with
the m8 a seven it's a burst rifle mavin
just like the m8 fan favor from black
ops 2 Merck looking so comfortable yet
again and there you go you see the clone
coming through he's gonna get shots in
but now
it's time to call in the health room
here it comes Kenny lights up mode and
there it is
able to pick up one TV unfortunately
taking it to the face there's he's going
to drop it it's gonna be a hundred point
advantage right now for Team DP they've
got this game lock down the baby needs a
turn out now and they're gonna be
pushing that Hill from the right side
you can see the spawns coming in go on
with one of them maybe buzz Oh as he
comes off the spawn see if he's gonna
make anything happen well check out buzz
oh he's gonna start to push for his
teammate cleans up one he's getting shot
from the right Abel come through you can
see via x-ray he's got one of his left
not gonna be able to clean that up but
only 42 points is team TP will stay with
buzz oh here through the Reese but
actually I see key bees on the three
Stroupe let's hop over here see if
keeping it keeping it going not that far
off the streaks panic yeah he has that
reject ability he can you know build
that up even when he's playing in the
hill he's able to come back second time
gives himself a good opportunity win I
think that's really where you're gonna
see you know the metagame develop know
in the pregame when are people gonna you
know know Tommy's a great player with
that reject bility but we have to ban
that a we've not worried about that or
are you worried about you know puzzle
using the mantle work there's also stuff
that you don't want in the game as well
so I love that the players the ones that
really decide all these things well we
do see Tommy on the three streak he's 38
and 26 leading all players he's got the
annihilator in hand can't he get forward
sees one more trying to line it up the
reload not in time gonna miss that shot
and eventually he will fall they only
need 30 points to close out game number
one team TV just cannot keep up right
now Matt so here's where the meta really
develops maven right you know Tommy
absolutely crushing here in game number
one we've seen him really dominate with
that Annihilator pistol point contested
the losing team is signed to bandit
going into the next game it's got to be
on their mind know one of the first
things that would need to go they're
gonna make a comeback in the series
that's the crazy thing too is we're
talking about different game types as
well I mean what's going to work really
well and our point may not work as well
in SMB what's working while s indeed not
the same for uplink so it's gonna be
amazing and you know obviously there has
me a ton of time for these games to kind
of develop meta and get forward with
these players but there's gonna be so
much overtime like the way this is going
to be so fun to watch out we love the
month day-to-day the meta is gonna
change in this game right no players are
gonna say hey for an obj player maybe
this specialist in this setup
works well then the next month one steam
start to adjust and don't ban some of
the things that the obj players use and
they're going to have to take a new kind
of default load so it's gonna change
from game game month month she's gonna
be amazing for call duties works well
I'm gonna go on with team TV Matt only
10 points mordida per team team they're
trying America level here maven they've
got enough time can they pull the
improbable you see the point stick it in
it should be at UVM here with the final
Hart boy they should be able to close it
out is they're going to get up inside
that's going to be 254 team DP as
they're able to close now let's give
them a round of applause and gate number
one
you